hey this is pressed Elle Walker and
you're watching mind your decisions
I want to thank ole mare from Israel for
suggesting this type of puzzle a B and C
play a series of one-on-one basketball
games in a given game two of them play
against each other while the third
person rests the loser of the game then
goes to rest while the winner continues
to play facing off against the person
who just rested after they were done
here is how many games each person
played a played in eight games be played
in 11 games C played in 15 games the
puzzle is who lost the fourth game this
seems like it will be impossible to
figure out but there is just enough
information can you figure it out give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching the video for a solution
[Music]
so let's start out with the number of
games each person played the first step
is to figure out how many games were
played in total since each game involves
two people if we add up the games played
by each person we will double count the
total number of games in other words the
sum of the games listed above is 2 times
the total number of games played so 2
times the total number of games played
is equal to 8 plus 11 plus 15 we can
solve that the number of games played is
then 1/2 of 34 which is equal to 17 so
how does that help us
well now let's consider the minimum
number of games played a person that Lu
every single game must still play every
other game this is because the loser and
the resting player rotate with each
other so a person playing in Game one
and then losing all games will play in
all odd-numbered games this is a total
of nine games similarly a person playing
in game two and then losing all games
will play in all even-numbered games
this will be a total of eight games now
notice a played in exactly eight games
logically eight games is the minimum
number of games a person can play since
a played in eight games we can conclude
a played and lost in all of the
even-numbered games thus a lost the
fourth game amazing did you figure it
out thanks for watching these math
videos which can be watched for free
inspire and build confidence for people
around the world and they already have
over a hundred million views with your
help we can share the beauty of
mathematics and make the world a better
place please subscribe for free to get
the newest videos watch and share all of
mind your decisions videos email me a
puzzle or math topic presh at mind your
decisions calm if you so choose you can
check out my books which are listed in
the video description and you can
support me on patreon to earn exclusive
rewards thanks for watching and thanks
for your support